citizens of the reject Nation you'll
believe a man can fly because we're
taking some adventures with Superman we
did four last time we're doing three
this time because it's a 10 episode
series two and five we're doing six
we're doing seven are you excited John
I'm so excited coin
because then eight nine ten set up
finale we got schemes we got plans you
guys seem to have enjoyed this so please
hit that like hit that notification Bell
hit that comment let us know what you
want us to watch next let us know how
you're enjoying this show let us know
what other Superman properties you enjoy
and let us know in general how are you
just curious doing well I hope you're
good as always if the folks over at
prepper see this thank you yes you are
how this is possible all the prepping
all the urine all the doing all the
editing we appreciate you as well as the
fine folks over at the patreon who are
the sexiest of all the rejects no
disrespect to the non-patrons they just
got a little sex appeal being patrons
and they get to watch this from front to
back beginning to end including our
resting watching faces
so if you want to watch us watch in its
entirety head on over to patreon and
become a patron without further Ado it
is time to dive into our adventures with
Superman in three two
oh that's so good her disgruntled face
today's the day
it's today I have to wake you up every
morning with an update on how close we
are to our camping slash Bigfoot Finding
Expedition but it's squats
watching time already my favorite
episode
flame bird response video
ever nah nah
you've got a YouTube rival he's got a
troll but also if that's his whole
kindness is just saying no I think we've
seen them all so are they gonna give
views I don't know if that's is that
really or no it'll probably turn into
one of those things where this guy
starts taking Jimmy's videos using them
getting more views than Jimmy does thus
proving that the system is problematic
if negativity always prevails but
Superman is about positivity don't let
anybody convince you otherwise going for
our squashing trip no I I mean that too
but I I'm going to tell Lois that I like
her yeah I think she's picked up on that
you know she's been staring at me
non-stop for the past day and speaking
of things that are today the camping
trip to find Bigfoot I like this shot
meet me at the bus stop at 5 PM yeah
that Train's gonna crash yeah I'm gonna
be late cover me until I get in thanks
yeah the split screen has like multiple
shots in it yeah it was clever giving
you credit
she came back without a bagel have you
noticed how often he steps out for
bagels does no one care about squatching
day there's this thing I think might be
true but it's crazy but I'm 99 sure I'm
right but before I do anything I need to
be a hundred percent sure I'm running a
little late can you cover for me oh
remember to meet me at the bus stop at 5
00 PM she's 100 sure that the Squatch is
real that's what that's what he's
definitely talking about squash
split screen turning into a wall clever
yeah the daily planet star reporter
Steve I know who you are please do not
they really are Team Rocket they really
are I asked Perry for a photographer for
a special assignment and you're it damn
it Perry it's very Ducks out
it's Squatch day let him Squatch all I
want is a Sasquatch crush the alarms
grab the gold and I'll hit the safe and
any trouble
make it double
right
why is all the text so Jake don't buy
second hand not attack what
cool choker though
[Music]
not a great guy these thieves no honor
amongst them live wire stole this Tech
and Unleashed it onto our city but
someone made these weapons and there's
something weirdly familiar about the
tech one of the planet's old dispatch
scanners
the tech weapons have shown up they've
nearly destroyed part of the city so if
we listen to the scanner we'll hear any
reports of the weapons and can
investigate this is the story I want to
pursue pretty good yeah let's ask
man about them me e u and Superman in a
room together at the same time she
hasn't learned nuances as a reporter yet
this is gonna be great you're the best
journalist I know I I value your input
and and this really matters to me people
have been hurt by these weapons you've
almost been hurt by them and I won't let
that happen again because I I am
Superman
I care about you and I uh
come on I wanted to ask reports of a
runaway I forgot all about my bagel in
the kitchen
really does love his Bagels
[Music]
this is very funny
let's sit up here and uh get to work
this
the bridge of the stadium a practice oh
no
did you just put it right up to his face
I don't know how we're gonna
photographer with a camera he is because
uh where's the viewfinder in Germany
flamebird says it's all real huh what I
say
Steve is not no oh that's so good how
did we not put that together it was
right there Jimmy has his own secret
identity perfect cover
okay now Lois thinks she can keep up
with Superman I'm doubting this come on
look at how many cats he's already saved
that's Superman you can't be here
there's a robbery in progress heard
about the break-in over the scanner
because my good friend is working on a
story about the tech
laughs
Clark Kent don't you oh that young man
who works with you and Mr Olsen he's
quiet but thoughtful upstanding I like
him
I think he's good for you
until Clark
can show up and ask you questions
himself oh my God we're not letting you
oh so
he's already here
damn it
oh my
[Music]
this must have happened in a comic but
it is kind of a neat idea cuff to
somebody yeah it's cute
check the VIN yes
sorry Superman please don't kidnap me
like the others what you're not you're
the guy who's been trolling me wait
you're flavored he's not good at secret
identity nope you dragged me out here to
blow off work for your video stream what
does Mr White know about this like you
kids do what Perry tells you I ain't
Fair
just me and my protege two lone wolves
making videos
offsides what you meant about kidnapping
or I let my flying friend here Cut Loose
that's not happening then I'll cut loose
Miss Lane please don't threaten people
it's wrong
[Laughter]
whoa but I'm not going down easy
God damn it bought the time
flame hop away first we have to go back
to the Daily Planet
two Targets headed in different
directions what's the priority Superman
yes Ryden go
so Metal Gear so Metal Gear this whole
show I'm not letting you go I'm sorry
yeah I can't let you get hurt Superman
man
Clark oh he must have heard that he
didn't got his superhero yeah there's no
way he he must have though I'm not
letting you take me
I'm not taking anyone I just want to
help
whoa blue flame concussive
nope fire tornado on the final Target
and Nemesis Omega suit is operating at
optimal efficiency integrating the
reclaimed Tech has made it stronger who
is the other one permission granted
requesting support
oticon
wonder if it's Lois's dad is it Sam Lane
maybe he's in the middle the military
looking hat on yeah
golly it's Gotta Be where the ice breath
comes in oh in your gangs freeze right
but how
who are you we're the good guys
sure agent Wilson contain it agent
Wilson
good old Slade Wilson an anime
[Music]
well that means he's not Deathstroke
power fluctuations are wildly off the
enemy is weaker than anticipated this
technology these these weapons they're
yours you're the ones kidnapping people
he's got a Super Brain too
whose voice is that drop the ACT
Superman there's no one here to swallow
your lies
you oh I'm the one keeping the earth
safe
hit him
I don't understand again no again
soups what's going on soups
yeah woof
[Music]
[Applause]
laser swords
yeah well bloodhaven blood Haven
dude
he's Wilson take the shot no not if it
endangered civilians remember why we're
doing this yeah dude well they thank you
for sparing a handful now Wilson
remember well it's cold operation Mandy
or is it mine Mandy Walla be seeing you
Superman
be seeing you in your righteous helping
people ass
you're hurt oh that's from shaving
Bagel don't lie to me again I've spent
all this time worrying about you and oh
is it gonna jump this is how you're
gonna play it play what
fine
do this the hard way
we'll believe a man can lie
you hated Superman you said he was a
liar and you were gonna find and publish
all of his Secrets my secrets I had no
idea it was you until after the gala how
could you think that you jumped off a
roof
I don't know what we were going to be oh
but that's all over now oh
or text if you
well four hours of no squatching hello
[Music]
perfect voicemail who needs them anyway
it's okay you'll find the Squatch Jim No
One's Gonna believe you but you'll find
him I will
whoa Gorilla Grodd yeah I assume unless
there's just gorillas in the forest at
Metropolis oh boy oh Jim
golly that was intense A lot happened
that episode big episode are we about to
get a post-credits scene right now oh
it's not zooming ahead they're not
whisking us away oh we're about to find
out who that mysterious military man is
I don't know it was very fun though that
was a good episode I like that a lot
yeah like I like the way this is all
developing and moving oh
no it helped just for the sadness of the
Polaroid all right gang get ready for
the next one dark here we are I'm so
sorry for standing you up which was
completely
I'm on my way to the campsite I'll see
you there oh good we're still squatching
I flew to the campground no Jimmy I flew
over the forest The Daily Planet nothing
he disappeared just like everyone who
came into contact with that tech oh no
Jimmy's on the suicide squad
it's inevitable let's get one thing
straight I'm doing this for Jimmy not
you we could be overreacting maybe he
just turned off his phone dude he was
texting you both all day stop
don't broke Jimmy no I read and I didn't
know this Metropolis canon in DC is in
Delaware what does that blow your mind I
couldn't settle into that yes it's so
specific and it's not any of the states
I would have guessed Delaware okay
according to the the DC map I found
because I was like I wonder what city
it's near because they do fictional in
in non-figure Delaware blew my mind
where's Central City we'll get into this
later I scouted the forest from the air
at least a dozen times how did I miss
this is it cloaked that would make sense
[Music]
whoa jeepers
my power's don't work in here
weird
it's like near the Red Sun I found
Jimmy's phone this is the
system
[Applause]
Bigfoot kidnap Jimmy yes
I've been kidnapped by Bigfoot girly God
yes
the spying ears
oh the brain the brain this is how I
thought it would end but at least I got
to meet a super intelligent French
gorilla before I died which means I was
right
go ahead and open my brain at least
someone cares what I think live stream
it
would you like to talk about it yes I
like that they're in love too I
appreciate that
when your kidnappers feel bad for you
Dark Times
is Cadmus uh a name that we should know
uh Katniss is the thing yeah okay cat
Miss minefield
hey buddy you know a Boston robotics dog
[Music]
is that the Loch Ness monster he's sworn
of debutants we lost in Scotland oh
conspiracy Theory's dream the CIA is
classified Sonic guns under development
until the Creator was seriously bad
the Creator didn't vanish we recruited
her yes you did adorable we belong to
Carlos the U.S government stops
sick we along with military division
task force eggs
while our sister program relished this
house we were not interested in
destruction
we use the technology
to create yeah an experiment gave me
super intelligence
hell yeah when it was discovered that we
were making things to challenge the
world not harm it task force x was sent
to eliminate us can't be having that
they Disturbed a most fragile
experiments
oh I lost his body
whoa
oh the black holitorium it's back Tokyo
lost in a black hole Jimmy
oh
oh hey oh
nice we're in the clear oh no oh no oh
golly
whoa naked soups
bring it back DC tradition yep
it's a very strong pants
my titanium pants
when we figure out how to stabilize it
it will become a wormhole a gateway to
other dimensions oh to the Bizarro world
as long as nasing disraps the flow of
power to this room it's perfectly safe
ugh damn it
love the design with the yeah it's
really cool big whole Chunk we need to
be careful who knows what could be
to us
hey
everyone stop this whole situation today
has made me realize that I held things
back from you and I shouldn't have I am
Clark I know you're Superman this is not
a big reveal
yes what yes we've been roommates since
freshman year the day I met you you
ripped the handle off of the door
amazing okay it's been a weird 24 hours
my Powers aren't working and we've been
chased all over this place by robots so
let's just take a deep breath and stop
yelling she jumped off a building yeah
it didn't really have a choice never
never created any robots
he's not one of ours
God these things it's good because
they're like they're formidable Tech but
they're also like kind of creepy the way
they move yeah
[Music]
what is going on we got bald hiding like
one year in and made a bunch of mutants
okay
eating a black hole and an army of
mutants we live a simple life a piece
[Music]
sexy frequency ratio 2.1778
magnitude
hey that's handy why did you cut me out
of a huge part of your life and me
because I was scared all I've ever
wanted is to be normal I don't want you
to treat me like an alien I just want to
be your friend oh buddy we're friends
because of who you are and we just want
oh careful buddy we need to open the
containment field and let's see black
hole hit critical mass for it to
stabilize
oh boy seems a little risky there garage
get another big old hole in your
building
are we gonna go in are we going already
it's all the rage right now
whoa
[Music]
whoa wow cool the general found you how
how did you your max woke up after you
entered our parameter the Omega field
affected you the tech reacts to you then
you're on the crosshairs of task force x
of him a man who would blot out the Sun
the guy from 300 the van we've been
hiding from because once he sees you as
a threat he will never ever stop you are
different like us but if you come back
we're doing an interview for flamberg
and the Daily Planet I think we need
some pictures though
no Harry might take some convincing to
become a True Believer like us
oh
signs of recent habitation I am a
gorilla I want your opinion on the tech
here but why would a humble kidnapped
billionaire like me do that because we
want the same thing was that parasite
healing to take down Superman when do we
start
big bad
got us a Suicide Squad
all right that was two out of three
gotta go back for those those voices I
want to know who voiced uh
the lovely couple
gorilla and the Brain Brain Brain Brain
Brain Brain Brain Brain the same thing
we do every day pinky try to avoid the
world yeah try to find a place that'll
accept our existence
oh it's back together put the photo back
cute gang we got episode seven here we
are one two it's already starting let's
see if the logos here's the rest of me
uh does the evil Tech kind of looks like
this Tech must be Krypton oh how do we
not put that blue versus red only
difference yeah maybe they took Krypton
Tech and retrofitted it why did you
bring me here I brought you here because
there's no bad guys no robots and
absolutely nothing to interrupt me when
I ask you this will you go on a date
with me
all right
so what is happening here buddy Jimmy
[Laughter]
so I've plotted a room and timed it
because I'm taking Lois out for the most
romantic evening of her life oh my God
I'll fly in to pick her up at 6 45 the
cherry blossom oh it's so cute Lois
deserves it one night with no talking
gorillas or freeze ray bank robbers just
me and her I mean I bet that talking
gorilla makes some good ass food normal
land yeah
Jimmy great I think I figured out the
perfect gift for Clark oh jeez
his past I can't fly or fight robots but
investigating finding answers this is
what I can do they're cute
oh no oh
Superman
hey I don't know he's like a Pokemon
nope you have the Multiverse son
nope Clark is Superman in almost every
reality this Earth Earth
we're going ballsaver
they did The Avengers oh that was
awesome yeah the 90s Superman was just
here in the 40s
that was delightful your Lois Lane she's
been kidnapped by a gang of
interdimensional criminals
interdimensional gang I
gling in you'll have to break through
their security whatever it takes you're
the Dependable Clark now let's go why do
I feel like you have something to do
with this though yeah you can't trust
the Mexican
oh oh good that gives me time to change
he knew the audience would believe it
because what we just saw this is clever
uh Lois Lane and Jimmy Olsen of verse 12
you need to come with us very
interdimensional Lois Lane I'm Lois Lane
that's Lois Lane and that's Lewis Lane
Lewis we are the league of Lois Lanes
League of Lois Clark Kent is in danger
[Music]
the Council of reads of Lois's
so much happening lowest Society of
America
these kidnappers Lair they're inside and
so slow is quick she doesn't have much
time yeah
trust you as far as I could throw you
[Music]
look out for their guard dog too
whoa cool the interdimensional
peacekeeping force the league of Lois
Lanes wow we were founded by Lois Prime
the first lowest to discover the
Multiverse amazing awesome how much Lois
are you my name's Jelena Olsen and
unfortunately it depends on you
he's so happy Jelena he calls himself a
chaos God we managed to disarm him but
as we were taking him in a portal opened
to a previously unknown Universe
Universe 12. if I ever get my hands on
the jerks who helped that gorilla and
the Brain open that stupid portal oh no
your Clark is helping him we tracked
Mixie here and now you're Clark and
Mixie are missing we need your help to
find him of course I'll do what I do
best investigate
once the scanner analyzes your
Dimensions tachyons we'll be able to
find your Clark if it helps Clark then
huh
in the meantime
oh just not in there what are you Lois
is hiding get you everybody hey Athena
Gary and mace a Green Lantern is that a
t was it a Mr terrific thing what is
that so many Easter eggs tea orb
robbing this place what no hey look
there's the good stuff
Dr Fate where is Lois Metropolis
probably how should I know oh Cosmic Rod
flight ring ooh no Lois was never in
danger
I deceived you I lied because portal
proof vaults are a huge inconvenience
and you are very strong but you're not
the quickest guy from Planet Krypton oh
shh let me break this glass no
no I got it
what's on the teeth I always finds that
is from Krypton is this little punk and
you may be stronger than me but can you
stop me I think
[Music]
does he have magic I lost something dear
to me I'm less than I was but strong
enough for one last trick ugh definitely
gonna be about the Multiverse wait
you're a flame bird out of all the
oceans in the Multiverse I've never met
another one yeah you've seen mines that
the cane remains of the secret
government laboratory that definitely
did not have a gorilla or a brain in it
telepathic
horse yes
all right what are you
cerebro it's the uh Amalgamated Universe
Earth 52 oh
Kingdom Hearts universe
Superman file X restricted access at
headquarters only so where is
headquarters yeah where's the lowest
center of the universe the Multiverse
analysis
found Mixie and Clark the scene is set
all we have to do is wait for them to
show up wait for who to show up sand
worms
[Music]
only thing that'll take down a clerk
he's too powerful to give the benefit of
the doubt no I won't let you do this we
know uh you didn't grab us to help you
you're not League material but you're
enough like us to cause problems
ouch councils always be like this man
can't trust the league got you
it's him he just said got you
oh
what is
[Music]
Clark no Jimmy I thought we were flame
Bros I'm sorry come on Olsen's step it
up now for you Criminal
what we don't stop until we find
oh damn it
huh yep
get away I'll keep an eye on Superman
start talking guys League headquarters
you know where it is I don't but Lois
Prime did which is why I nabbed her
recorder you're not gonna try to stop me
the other Lois is are hiding something
from me about Superman you're gonna take
us to HQ and I'm gonna find out what it
is yep you met a legion of yourself and
the first thing you did was suspect them
of lying
lowest Prime would have loved you
because she didn't trust anyone either
which is why she kept a secret backup
master key now I know which Lois you are
you're the fun one
I like that they waste no time with
these plot lines they just go there they
don't punch yeah
yeah
sweet
this is a fire ha
welcome to the future but it's now time
to take back what ah mine
oh God
[Music]
is the spot now I'm gonna need to get
you off my back
all of you oh no this is real bad
ah you look Gremlin a lot of mixes this
is my fault I wanted to give you a
normal first date without any Superman
weirdness but this is the weirdest yet
I've seen I've seen vials I'm literally
the worst lowest in the Multiverse you
would be better off with anyone else oh
they're all pretty evil or at least
heartless I love going on adventures
with you Clark I love your Brilliance I
love your kindness I love
I love
oh
cute nicely done
[Music]
wow cool
goodbye Dependable Clark oh boy
oh boy but I am strong enough
for one last trick
not so tough without your hat
Jimmy definitely record that great great
mixy political story that's awesome I
like this as for you three where did
they go they grabbed a gauntlet while we
were busy the computer's too fried to
find their universe's coordinates again
yeah
you always trust the flame bro to have
your back
9 30 p.m oh they're always like a cat
meow when they say that I think flame
bird has a sound
oh Jimmy
greatest Swing Man of the Multiverse
it's too late for dinner but I was
thinking no treat me to Coffee
Smallville yeah for a Smallville
[Music]
oh no how do you work oh what you gotta
find out after the perfect coughing
oh is it Ultraman and stuff
Zack Snyder Superman
that's right
beginning of BBS
have you figured it out yet
ugh weren't you in jail I was it didn't
take besides your drama is too fun to
miss is this some kind of trick oh no
it's the truth just like not every Lois
wins a Pulitzer oh only seeing the evil
ones though not every Superman is good
oh no oh wow what is it you figure it
out so that's how we get kryptonite on
Earth 12. yeah
wolf
oh man wow so what happened so many
things to
both anticipate and unpack I mean we
learned it's another Earth which allows
for all the variations
and yeah I mean you know Kryptonite as
of just a you know a device a device as
fuel for Weaponry various other things
now yep now it's on planet
yeah and I'm like if we are to get a Lex
Luthor or something like that at some
point you know I'm
like what's the the other guy in the lab
was named Alex
yeah it's true too that's true it looks
like we gotta pop a lane so we got a lot
of Supporting Cast of villainy oh boy
that makes he was great that was really
fun I did like I I think over these
seven episodes thus far I have been
really kind of enthralled by and and
pleased by the fact that they'll set
these things up and instead of just
flirting with them they will just full
on go like instead of being like
but we'll get there like season three no
they're like no it's happening yeah and
it's like I get the sense that not every
episode will have to be multiversal but
now it's just a possibility it's part of
the world and now it's yeah gonna open
up further doors for you know more and
more strangeness to happen and I also
appreciate that this they really do a
nice weave of cereal and episodic
storytelling because like the
circumstances do feel like they kind of
domino even though episodes have their
their own independent Arc yeah their own
flavor their own Focus all that stuff
also they made it very very clear with
this Multiverse that was can keep going
in the DCU yeah totally like I
remembered them they separated they had
the the old 90s and earlier classic
animated like shown which means it's all
allowed to be Canon yeah totally
that was fun and like like you were
saying with like getting into stuff
right away like we learned about Lois
knowing quickly we learned about Jimmy
knowing quickly we've we've really
established a lot in a hurry and now we
have parasite we have mixy we had Grodd
yeah I want to get the the voices up
here too because I really appreciated
like I really enjoyed uh the back and
forth between God and brain yeah and
their relationship and just like yeah
having again yeah like you have these
it's very fitting to have some kind of
shadowy laboratory uh in here
I guess would have been his name oh is
that not gorilla girl I mean escrow
garage not as smart yeah is there I
maybe I failed this city and I do not
know either way well that's the thing
too is it's interesting to see because
they don't always go for like you know
the most recognizable name voice actor
but I think the voice acting across the
board has been really nice like really
uh you know distinct and and with lots
of personality and and yeah like this
would probably be my first uh mixes
story and uh and yeah like what a fun
wild sort of impish presence that is
yeah and then to pit that against the
like Council of of Lois's you know I'd
love if I mean a time travel casting
because that's always like the dream of
infinite possibility Danny DeVito
like Danny DeVito Mixie would be amazing
I like it could probably do it now but I
mean it's gonna be a lot of wire work
yeah but I would love a Mixie Danny
DeVito yeah totally uh he's such a good
villain when used right and I love that
they Incorporated the Hat element I love
the actual chaos I love videos
threatening but also like seemingly
defeatable and then like wasn't it
there's just a lot of fun with that
character yeah yeah and I really like
the way that they've handled the yeah
revealing of Clark's identity the way
they handled it with Lois versus Jimmy I
thought was really nice Jimmy's like I
always knew and I love the conspiracy
theorist like knowing and like just
protecting his friend and you've got a
little bit of jealousy there and they
all have good arguments as to why they
behave the way they did and you know
even though part of you is sitting there
going like whoa how would you explain
this to somebody like the points they
all make from their perspectives are
still all valid and you come around to
Jimmy it's gonna be like you told her
first you know yeah you know which is
cute but it also it all makes sense and
it all kind of feels like it happened
naturally from the momentum of all these
different colliding events and stuff
like that and I don't think I've ever
seen a Multiverse story told in the
season one so I really like that this
allows for like infinite continuity
because it doesn't have to tie to
anything and it allows for the comic to
happen simultaneously and like I said
the DCU like this is establishing itself
as its own thing so nothing has to be
done yeah it all can be whatever they
want it to be yeah totally and I like
this as a trio of episodes too because
now you have yeah you have your formed
idea that task force x is a big
formidable you know Earth threat or at
least a a shadowy imposing presence
that's at odds to some extent with
Superman you get the you know check back
in with the tech in episode five you
stand Jimmy up for Squatch day yeah and
then you know you have the whole thing
with him and Steve which I thought was
cute and then the sixth episode is him
going squatching and finding this lab
and and that felt like wonderfully
self-contained and yeah these three
episodes are a perfect Arc like we we
didn't know that we just picked because
we were like we didn't want to watch
episode nine and ten by itself so we're
like let's do three and then this ended
up being a great like mini move yeah
yeah it's like I love Mullen brain in
the woods I loved
the juxtaposition they're really good at
misleading you and feeding you things
that you think like okay this is some
like you know shadowy uh military base
or something like that and they're like
no you brought those robots here we're
just here yeah yeah we're just hiding
out trying to live a peaceful existence
here uh and then with the Mixie episode
to have it be that yeah he comes in and
he's like oh I need your help you know I
need you to come and you know save Lois
or whatever it is and then and then it
turns out he's just like tricking him
into doing stuff and then in the edit
you're watching Lois in our mind get
kidnapped and then she has her own C in
a second later that shows it wasn't
which is really clever because that's
mischievous at us yeah totally and it's
like it's it's well uh I feel like there
are probably slight variations in like
the uh image that uh Mixie shows
Superman of Lois being they used a very
different camera angle than they've used
I noticed that they used a more Dynamic
angle maybe like that Universe would
look different and she probably looked
like you said slightly different but
yeah the angle I was like that's a very
bold angle and like then it wasn't her
Universe yeah yeah yeah totally and and
I just love that yeah too uh that gives
you that gives way uh really nicely to
yeah just I don't know it's very
graceful it's like it's fun it's clever
it gets Superman yeah and it really
seems like across the board against
Superman and even though there were
moments in that uh seventh episode where
I was like well I could kind of talk to
him or at least get a sense for like who
he is and stuff like I also get that
they're like well you know this we've
seen the ways this could go sour we
can't just you know uh proceed with kid
gloves just because you think your Clark
is fine and they addressed pretty
head-on like my frustration with Lois
not knowing how to be a reporter because
like they were like you know we should
the other one had already won a Pulitzer
by her age and I was like oh yeah
because she is not good at that part
yeah and they like Yeah because it has
been bothering me that Intrepid or
portal Lois Lane cannot do like the
normal human reportery tasks but in this
universe she's not as good yeah at that
skill yeah and two I mean like the the
way in which she like leverages Mixie
and and gets the information which is
the lowest we know and love and yeah the
investigative reporting but using it as
investigating like pursuing and tracking
like yeah it's a really fun little play
on it yeah and the multiversal uh you
know Olson's helping each other out is
like there's just so many nice knowing
flourishes and I too I love that
culmination of them trying to have the
date and then they're standing there
together and they're both going like
these are what I perceive to be my flaws
and insecurities and then returning to
each other but this is what I love about
you and these are the qualities I see
yeah which is like such a nice again
there's heartwarming they're really good
at these juxtapositions that yeah either
warm your heart or mislead you in fun
ways or set up you know like there's
also just like a really fun bouncy like
joyous kind of humor there's without
having to be like jokey yeah there are
times when it is like when when uh Jimmy
and uh and what was her name
is something
I don't remember when they're geeking
out and she's like I saw the this
telepathic horse like they dive into it
which feels very much like there's a 12
issue miniseries
um with Jimmy Olsen specifically I think
it's called like Superman's friendships
jelana yeah uh and like it's basically
multiversal Jimmy Olsen stories and it's
out of continuity and it's just full
chaos for 12 issues but there's one
through line Jamie that goes in and out
of multiverses and like has these
elements and this reminded me a lot of
that and it's like one of the best uh
comics in the last five years and yeah I
would love to read something like that
yeah it's real special it won like three
eisner's I think it was like 2021 it was
either 2020 2021 uh it's literally just
Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen and it's a
really insane Maxi series oh fun hey
also shouts out to ozric Chow from
Supernatural voicing Lewis Lane good old
Kevin
um but yeah I thought this was a great
Trio I've I've really been loving every
episode's gotten better for me yeah like
I really enjoyed one through four but I
think seven is my favorite like I think
it's just gotten better and better and
better yeah I mean like this this to me
feels like the the joy of both like the
imagination and The Whimsy that comic
books can bring the Whimsy that cartoons
can bring and it all feels like again
you are certainly much more well-versed
but this all feels like Superman to me
some of the dialogue is so spot on where
like I just you know I didn't know I was
bulletproof and I knew you weren't and
like those moments are pure and Superman
yeah and and you see a montage of him
doing stuff around metropolis and you're
like oh he saved a cat but he also saved
like lots of other people and he fought
some robots and there's like a little
bit of everything happening and hey
Canon Multiverse there are Superman that
might break zod's neck and I made a
reference to one Insider fans are gonna
be real angry at me but that is Snyder
Superman which is Canon and totally fair
different Earth yes it is and I love
that Ultraman got reference because
ultraman's a real some and that'll
be fun to see if we go there also I
liked your uh your notice about the
Kryptonian Tech I'm curious if that
comes to play I feel like it it must I
feel like and that too we've also we we
have at least had Krypton named and the
con concept that I feel like we're going
to address Krypton and his real Roots
tonight we got you know hit Zod uh not
mentioned uh draw L mentioned earlier
yeah totally totally totally and and you
know we still have Mysteries to discover
within the ship yeah and we still have a
Fortress of Solitude I imagine to get to
it so I'm curious if we get Lex in the
finale yeah and if that Alex was Lex I I
feel like at this point that would be a
that I would put money in this Theory
koi but I agree I feel like the the
first four episodes were really nice
like yeah setting everything up getting
to know just sort of the day-to-day in
Metropolis and then this middle chunk
we've done was like okay now let's
really shoot outward into sci-fi and
fantasy and stuff like that like it was
so much there's so much play in the show
yeah and it's really well grounded by
the characters it's fun we like it we're
excited for the finale uh we're gonna be
doing the final three as a unit when the
finale drops so please leave a comment
and let us know what else you want us to
dive into we see your Young Justice
comments but we got to get these
episodic ones up uh because the movies
tend to do better than the uh the
episodic so if you want us to do stuff
like that like subscribe share this
video everyone let the people know
because we want to keep doing stuff like
this so that's how it's done uh but we
got a page on the day Shadow
want to shout out Michael B
you today Michael B's got a terrific
YouTube channel called Omni media with a
one where the eye would go and I know
these fellow I know I know him of the
Omni media yeah now I know his real
identity and he become an identity oh
yeah we just revealed it what are you
gonna do now media we know you're
Michael B Jordan that's right that's
right revealed Creed over here great
directing in Creed Three I was very
impressed oh yeah and we see those anime
influences peeking through incredible
gains as well exactly most jacked
reactors on YouTube and also reacting to
my Adventures of Superman so go support
his videos as well he's been helping uh
helping us figure out how to get these
out check out his videos on this very
show we just enjoyed Yes siree barbarino
that's a Multiverse of reactions that's
it certainly we were the Earth 12 he's
Earth 11 watching it his experience
different than our experience we're all
experiencing watching the multiverses
together through the power of the
internet all right reject Nation much
much much appreciated do all the YouTube
things likes and clicks and types and
things and we'll be back for the finale
Trio of episodes gotta be great we'll
see you very soon much love
foreign